replica indicate shoot deploy
the navigation has confirmed that the
parachute has deployed and we are seeing
significant deceleration
in the velocity our current velocity is
450 meters per second at an altitude of
about 12 kilometers from the surface of
mars
heat shield set perseverance has now
slowed to subsonic
speeds and the heat shield has been
separated this allows
both the radar and the cameras to get
their first look at the surface
current velocity is 145 meters per
second and an altitude of about
10 km nine and a half kilometers above
the surface
now filter converge lastly solution 3.3
meters per second
altitude 7.4 kilometers now has radar
lock on the ground
current velocity is about 100 meters per
second
6.6 kilometers of the surface
perseverance is continuing to descend on
the parachute
we are coming up on the initialization
of terrain relative navigation
and subsequently the priming of the
landing engines our current velocity is
about 90 meters per second at an
altitude of 4.2 kilometers
ovf valid we have confirmation that the
lander vision system has produced a
valid solution
and part of terrain relative navigation
priming
pba is nominal we have timing of the
landing engines
back shell set current velocity is 83
meters per second at about 2.6
kilometers from the surface of mars
we have confirmation that the back shell
has separated we are currently
performing the divert maneuver
current velocity is about 75 meters per
second at an altitude
of about a kilometer off the surface of
mars
deer and safety bravo we have
completed our terrain relative
navigation current speed is about
30 meters per second altitude of about
300 meters
off the surface of mars
we have started our constant velocity
accordion which means we are
conducting the sky crane about to
conduct the fly crane maneuver
skytrain maneuver has started
about 20 meters off the surface
we're getting signals from mro
tango delta touchdown confirmed
perseverance
faithfully on the surface of mars ready
to begin seeking the sands of past life